An absolutely astonishing trailer for the
Godzilla sequel King of the Monsters just
dropped.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to explain all
about the new monsters in the Godzilla 2 trailer
and I'll be revealing their special connection
with Millie Bobby Brown and Vera Farmiga's
characters.
This image of a frozen King Ghidorah is simply
stunning.
Now, we've known since we saw those paintings
of a dragon-like creature in the end credits
of Kong: Skull Island that King Ghidorah would
be appearing in this film, but this gorgeous
image of the three-headed winged serpent suspended
in icy Antarctica is still a delightful surprise.
And that shot of him spreading his wings,
with the lightning behind him, is another
stunner because not only is Ghidorah's body
capable of conducting electrical currents,
but he also heats water vapour in the air
creating a localised but devastating storm
system with thunder and lightning as he travels.
Ghidorah was a powerful enemy of Godzilla,
Mothra and Rodan when he first appeared in
Ghidorah: The Three-Headed Monster.
In the 1964 Toho movie, the monstrous dragon
was an extra-terrestrial being that hatched
from an egg which initially appeared to be
a meteor.
Ghidorah attempted to take over the Earth
until Mothra stood up to him, with Godzilla
and Rodan eventually deciding to team up with
her to defeat Ghidorah and send him back to
space.
So, I wonder if the filmmakers have gone with
an alien backstory for Ghidorah in the new
movie.
Then there's this majestic shot of Godzilla
rising from the sea and unleashing his "atomic
breath", and as if that wasn't enough, it's
followed by a stunning shot of a beautiful
bioluminescent Mothra in what looks like a
waterfall spreading her wings until she fills
the full screen with her wingspan which measures
over 800 feet.
And shout-out to the haunting music, Debussy's
Claire de Lune, which works beautifully in
this moment and throughout the trailer.
As the name suggests, Mothra is a moth-like
creature that has often been portrayed as
a saviour, and according to the Monarch Sciences
website, this version is a 'devastating guardian
angel' whose 'beta-wave bioluminescence […] can
be projected through the intricate patterns
on its wings and weaponised into blinding
"god rays"'.
Mothra is one of movie studio Toho's most
popular kaiju and is surpassed only by Godzilla
in the number of movies that she's appeared
in.
She did go up against Godzilla in the 1964
movie Mothra vs Godzilla and also in 1992's
Godzilla vs Mothra.
Next up is Rodan, a type of pteranodon that
first appeared on the big screen in Toho Studios'
1956 movie Rodan, and was initially a foe
of Godzilla's in the 1964 movie "Ghidorah:
The Three-Headed Monster".
In this film, Rodan has been lying dormant
in the Isla de Mona volcano, and we see this
"fire demon" returned to life in the trailer
as it sweeps over a city, leaving a trail
of destruction behind it.
And that's because its 870-foot wingspan creates
a sonic thunderclap capable of levelling entire
cities as it flies overhead.
By the way, this gorgeous but devastating
image really reminded me of Game of Thrones.
Speaking of which…
"Long live the King!"
Could that line have been any more Game of
Thrones?!
I feel like all Charles Dance is missing with
that dark, high-necked top he's wearing, is
his Hand of the King badge!
Details of Dance's character haven't been
revealed yet, but I wonder if he's part of
the mysterious organisation that's kidnapped
Millie Bobby Brown and Vera Farmiga's characters
and plans to use the creatures for its own
ends.
Obviously, any movie featuring Millie Bobbie
Brown and monsters is going to draw comparisons
with Stranger Things.
And this particular image here of Brown reaching
out to Mothra while her mother stands behind
her, reminded me of Eleven confronting the
Shadow Monster with Hopper.
By the looks of this scene though, Brown's
encounter with the creature seems a lot less
life-threatening than her monstrous face-to-face
in Stranger Things.
In fact, speaking to EW, Brown said that once
her character Madison understands Godzilla,
"there's some mutual respect for each other"
and she also added that Madison "has been
taught to not be scared of any monsters."
I imagine that will be because of her paleobiologist
mother, who works for the monster-tracking
organisation Monarch.
Indeed, according to actress Vera Farmiga,
the character she plays "has figured out a
way to communicate with the creatures and
potentially control them using their bioacoustics
on a sonar level."
In contrast to the shot with Mothra, this
other image here seems a lot more menacing
because although you might have thought that
was Godzilla in the background, look really
carefully and you'll see three eyes meaning
that's actually the 3-headed Ghidorah looming
over Brown.
I think Brown's character Madison will be
one of the keys to defeating Ghidorah alongside
Godzilla and the other monsters.
And given Farmiga's words throughout the trailer,
I feel the movie's going to have a "people
are the real monsters" vibe.
"Our world is changing."
"The mass extinction we feared..."
"... has already begun."
"And we are the cause."
"We are the infection."
In fact, Farmiga has said that, for her, the
film is about saving the environment.
So, what do you think about the Godzilla:
King of the Monsters trailer?
And did you spot any other interesting details
or have any theories about the movie?
Let me know your thoughts below, and if you
enjoyed this, a thumbs-up is always appreciated.
Tap left to check out more of my monster movie
playlist or tap right for another video you're
sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!